Senate Democrats go into full meltdown
our president calls his former hooker a
horse-faced and Stephen Hawking warns of
the cyborg apocalypse from beyond the
grave then Google doesn't evil and
subsequently exposes the weaknesses of
neoliberalism plus we will see Democrats
employing the same strategies they're
doing now even 20 years ago in the case
of Robin Williams
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
all right you horse faces we have a lot
to get to today before we get to that
let's make a little money honey how
about that I want to talk to you about
software advice because when you're
dealing with a real head-scratcher
having your go to person on call that is
a no-brainer which is why I've got to
tell you about software advice this is
very important and I wish that I'd known
about this when I've worked on campaigns
I've worked in other small businesses
you can waste a lot of time and you
waste a lot of money trying to figure
out the right software solutions for
your business and time and money it's
both it's the same thing right one
you're wasting your time trying to
figure out which is best for you and
then if you finally pick one it can be a
very costly mistake if you don't know
what you're doing so when it comes to
picking the right software for your
business software advice has done all
the research for you they can get you
working more effectively right away and
it's absolutely free this is the best
part because it's a price that you can
afford just go to software advice.com
slash knowles canada wles
you will be connected with an advisor to
discuss the best software options for
your needs
it takes just 10 minutes or less and
it's free so if you don't have 10
minutes or less to spend not spending
money and helping out your business I
don't know what you're doing if you're a
medical professional construction
manager or HR pro you name it really
anything software advice will save you
time and money if you're an entrepreneur
you work solo it is a great way to get
an expert opinion even without the
resources of a big company in the
software struggle today go to software
advice.com slash knowles canon wles that
is software advice.com slash Knolls kena
w elias connect with an advisor for free
software vice comm slash knowles
I gotta tell ya when I realized
yesterday that I didn't have a show I
was out giving a speech to a Republican
club around here I I was really upset
because the the morning opened up with
horseface
you know I Lisa wakes up before I do
sweet little ELISA so you know she's
reading the news and she just wakes me
up Mac Mac wake up horseface wake up you
got a lot of news to read Mac so so
let's see this the president called his
former hooker a horse face specifically
he tweeted out quote federal judge
throws out stormy Daniels lawsuit versus
Trump
Trump is entitled to full legal fees at
Fox News great now I can go after horse
face and her third-rate lawyer in the
great state of Texas
she will confirm the letter she signed
she knows nothing about me a total con
horse face obviously referring to stormy
Daniels I have the opposite reaction to
this that I think virtually everyone
else did so we'll get into why I think
this was actually not a terrible
political move in a second not exactly
polite not exactly chivalrous but
politically it actually might have been
a smart move but first we're actually
very fortunate to be joined now by
stormy Daniels I think this is an
exclusive on the Michael Knowles show to
get Miz Daniels's reaction to the Trump
tweet miss Daniels what what do you make
of it and why did you start this fight
with him you know this battle of names
obviously you first called you called
out president Trump for his genitalia
and you put that in your book and that
then he's responding to this why did you
start that fight in the first place
[Music]
mmm-hmm understood that makes sense
obviously if you publish a book with
scintillating details about the shape of
the president's member then you can fill
up that feedbag a little bit more make a
little more money honey I totally
understand that I totally understand
that tendency let's not forget before we
get into the rudeness of it all it's so
rude it's so rude she did start this
fight she did the president slept with
this porn star allegedly in what 2006
something like that they have a
one-night stand and then he offers her
some money she doesn't take the money
then before the election it seems that
she blackmails the guy and he wants her
to sign a nondisclosure agreement he
pays her what was one hundred thirty
thousand hundred fifty thousand dollars
to keep quiet
money not very well spent because she
didn't keep why it came out she started
talking about it total violation of even
the blackmail NDA that she had been
pushing for all the money she received
then she publishes this book says she
publishes this book where she says
president Trump's little little Donald
Donald jr. and I'm not talking about his
son resembles the mushroom character
from Mario Kart and on and on what we
know about Donald Trump is that he
responds to every single attack any
attack that you make on him he will
return five times as hard doesn't matter
if you're a man woman child you know
anything he will hit back it doesn't
matter if you are John McCain powa and
Vietnam he hits back against anybody and
she started the fight we saw this with
the Rosie O'Donnell thing you know Rosie
O'Donnell attacked Donald Trump Donald
Trump was merciless and vicious toward
her but she did start it so that's
that's the first side of this now is it
ever nice to say these things about
women no is it ever nice to say these
things about the hooker that you were
sleeping with while your wife was
pregnant No do I recommend that people
do it no that said this stormy Daniels
made this a political battle she decided
to blackmail a presidential candidate
she decided to violate her
non-disclosure agreement
he decided to try to attack the
president in an election year in a
midterm election year and so he's got to
fight back I mean the reason we elected
Donald Trump is because he fights back
finally now I want to analyze this this
language a little bit too because I
think politically it was a good attack
why the the kind of consensus
conservative view is that this
squandered all of the good news the good
news is he won the defamation ruling the
court threw out avenatti threw out
stormy Daniels and gave a win to
President Trump that's the good news
and he is stepping on it by calling her
horse face I don't think that's true I
don't think anybody would report that he
won that ruling that defamation ruling
if he didn't make it saucy with
something like horse face if he didn't
we wouldn't be talking about it maybe on
this show we would have mentioned it but
it wouldn't have gotten any play in the
media the reason it's getting play is
cuz he called his former prostitute
horse face and so everyone is running
with that on NBC on the New York Times
Washington Post all of that and then you
have to ask well why did he call her
horse face oh it was well he won that
defamation ruling against her so I
actually think politically it's pretty
smart and I don't think that you need to
be some conspiratorial mastermind 4d
chess person to think so
Donald Trump is a media manipulator that
is essentially what this guy is he is
has been doing it since the 1980s he is
the greatest media manipulator of his
age he's doing it again in this tweet he
knows exactly what he's doing he knows
exactly what effect the the words will
have I'd also like to point out on the
nickname itself it's a pun I don't think
people have noticed this horseface to
refer to his [ __ ] she's a she takes
money to have sex with people so the
horse fish he's saying her face looks
like a horse and she's a [ __ ] and it's
a horse face again I don't think this is
conspiratorial he's really good with
nicknames
he knows what nicknames will stick he
knows why they stick low-energy Jeb
little Marco lyin Ted crooked Hillary
he's really good at this he does it all
the time and horseface is one of these
and and the reason that we're talking
about it the reason we're spending so
much time talking about it even on this
show is because of the name
but what does the name represent that
the stormy Daniels thing was a force
that it was nothing it went nowhere and
it reminds us it keeps at the front of
our minds that she lost this battle
Michael avenatti the third-rate lawyer
lost this battle who won the battle
President Trump and a reminder that he's
he's very good at language now I want to
get into the Democrat meltdown there has
been nothing short of a total Democrat
meltdown here you've you've looked at
the case you know that the Senate races
across the country let me put this in
perspective for you yesterday in the
state of Nevada a GOP candidate for
state legislature and a pimp he was a
pimp and a brothel owner was discovered
dead in his bed by legendary porn star
ron jeremy after a campaign brothel
party at which sheriff joe arpaio and
tax reform hero grover norquist were in
attendance and that tucker carlson
called in to pimp GOP candidate brothel
owner brothel party 70s porn star joe
arpaio grover norquist that is like not
even a headline today that is so not the
news of the day that might be the fifth
wildest political story of the day that
tells you something about the democratic
party going into full meltdown mode what
is going on obviously the biggest one is
elizabeth warren this is trippy Heitkamp
it's true they don't work and beta or
robert Francis O'Rourke it's true of all
of these racism but the Liz Warren one
is just too delicious the Cherokee
Nation has come out now and issued a
statement saying stop pretending to be
Native American you're not Native
American this is a fraud you should
apologize
total PR disaster I don't I like to give
politicians their due when it comes to
little PR stunts even if they're
Democrats this was an unmitigated
disaster a complete backfire on Liz
Warren she could have walked outside and
just repeatedly stepped on a rake it
would have been less of a self-inflicted
wound than what she did with this stupid
DNA test
even MSNBC the left-wing news outlet is
making fun of her for this you're there
this DNA the DNA test results best I can
gather according to your papers
reporting she's one one thousand
something like I think I might be just
as Native American as she is on MSNBC
statistically speaking he that guy is
he's probably more Native American than
she is the average American is one point
eight percent Native American the
average white person and she is one one
thousand twenty fourth and she thought
this was going to work so now she's in
in total damage control mode she's
tweeting she's trying to go into damage
control mode here is I think this is the
most compelling damage control
commercial that the warren campaign has
put out so far take a look I'm not even
gonna explain that for the people who
were just listening to this show right
now you have to go online and watch that
clip I think you know people can stop
it's the one one little tear going down
I don't know if that one's gonna work
either though absolutely awful you know
she really you might say she really
tried to Buffalo the American people on
this one hmm you might say the response
was really a savage mmm all right enough
of that
so the Cherokee Nation comes out against
her they say please stop pretending to
be a Native American and then you know
Donald Trump calls her Pocahontas this
has now added this whole episode has
added a number of new nicknames to the
popular consciousness
alaya wathah polka honky Chiefs
spreading bull on and on and on now a
Pocahontas descendant her name is Debbie
white of Perico Perico is coming out and
calling on Liz Warren to apologize as it
makes a mockery of Native Americans I
don't know I I take it that this Native
American family married into the
Italians at some point if with a name
like debbie wiped up Perico maybe not I
don't know but she does she should
apologize Liz Warren should apologize
she can't apologize now
I think the idea was I'm gonna go out
I'm gonna show that I'm gonna hit back
she's actually ironically Liz Warren is
trying to learn the lessons of the trump
era she's trying to emulate Donald Trump
cos Donald Trump punches he fights back
he'd but it doesn't work when people who
are not Donald Trump try to be Donald
Trump do you remember you know little
Marco doing the Rickles routine it does
not work they don't get this lesson you
can only be yourself you can only bring
yourself to politics
I mean look everything you've ever done
is gonna be exposed your character is
gonna be exposed it's gonna be tested
you're gonna be exhausted you can have
all these fair and unfair attacks
against you you can only be yourself the
inauthentic things are gonna wash away
especially in this era with 4k and
social media and 24/7 news you can only
be yourself she isn't this person she's
not good at fighting back I think her
20/20 hopes are over I am I'm willing to
make that prediction now actually which
is so early to do it but I think it's
over I mean even for Vice President I
think she would have a very hard time
it's more plausible for a VP spot I
thought she was fatally wounded mortally
wounded even before this debacle this
DNA test again because of this
authenticity thing and again because
what we know about Liz Warren first of
all she's grating she's annoying she's
elitist she's arrogant she's all of
these things she's not an attractive
candidate outside of Massachusetts was
that her tribe know she's Cherokee not
message Massachusetts so she wasn't a
great candidate nationally in that
regard anyway but after this I mean you
know it in in the beginning all we knew
is she's a fraud she passed herself off
as something that she patently is not
for decades and decades beginning in the
eighties doubling down in the 90s so I
thought that would hit her if she had
just not addressed it and just left it
up to people's imagination maybe she
could have pulled the Clinton and said
oh that's old news
you know the Clintons would always do
this they would they would commit some
scandal and then they would Stonewall
reporters when they would ask about it
or Stonewall Republicans when they would
ask about it and then years later they'd
say it's old news it's not old news you
just haven't answered it until now and
now you're saying it's it's old
she might have been able to do that but
after this the gamble left her far worse
off now we know she's one one-thousandth
maybe maybe one one-thousandth Native
American it really hits her this also
teaches another lesson of 2018 which is
denied denied denied till you die it's
sort of a sad state of our politics that
there's no grace and there's no mercy
and there's no repentance right now but
you see it with the me2 movement the the
people who admitted to sexual misconduct
in Hollywood in corporate America and in
politics the ones who admitted and
apologized are dead they re jail they
have had their careers ruined they're
like they get Kevin Spacey they get cast
into the outer darkness where there's
weeping and gnashing of teeth
the ones who deny do fine the ones who
deny basically can survive it Ben
Affleck denied he survives it these
other media moguls who deny they
survived it some politicians who denies
or Bob Menendez can survive it that is
the lesson that's kind of sad because it
means we're in a particularly shallow
moment where we don't have a sense of
mercy we don't have a sense of grace
we're just out for blood red for revenge
right for justice but that is the fact
and candidates who are running this year
I have to watch out for that hopefully
it'll change in the future because I'd
rather live in a world where you can say
oh yeah ten years ago I did that thing
and I shouldn't have done it I feel bad
I haven't done it since I don't want to
do anymore say okay that's fine but we
don't we don't live there right now so
if you're running in 2018 deny until you
die that's all you can do
America's not feeling particularly
remorseful at the moment the other total
collapse beyond Liz Warren is Heidi
Heitkamp of North Dakota Heidi Heitkamp
if you haven't seen this story she
released a full-page newspaper ad
listing the names purportedly of sexual
assault victims so women who say I was
sexually assaulted I was and she lists
their names in a newspaper ad for her
campaign and then it turns out the women
never gave their permission to be in the
ad and then it turns out some of the
women were not sexually assaulted
they actually deny ever having been
sexually assaulted what was heidi
heitkamp thinking i mean there whatever
aid took out this newspaper ad what were
they thinking this is the meet to
hysteria in full-swing you want to talk
about a pendulum going back and forth
this is absurd you're now outing people
who were raped or sexually assaulted and
don't want it to be known because of the
stigma attached to it and then you're
just making it up for other people where
did they get this list one of the women
Katie Miller said quote a lot of these
people listed including me did not get
give anyone permission for our names to
be posted I don't even support Heidi
Heitkamp and I am NOT a domestic abuse
survivor obviously whatever staffer put
this together has long been fired and
probably murdered but could you imagine
Heidi Heitkamp space she was already
facing a really tough reelection fight
she got killed in this Kavanagh thing
because she doubled down on the
character assassination and so she was
already 1012 points behind her
Republican opponent now could you
imagine her face the jaw just dropping
and hitting the floor she immediately
went into damage control mode and issued
an apology but probably too little too
late here she is the only thing I can do
is say it I am so sorry I'm not going to
ask for forgiveness but I want to know
what we can do to fix this and so it's
not that this is I'm not minimizing in
any way Scott this this event I think
that this is horrible
and I look at this the way I would if I
were someone whose name was in the paper
who didn't authorize it and I think that
that is a colossal and huge mistake for
which I will undoubtedly you know you
know have have reputational injury as a
result of it but I'm not worried about
that I'm worried about fixing what we've
done and the mistake that's been made
she even botched the apology I mean she
had the right instinct which is oh dear
god I have to apologize right now
Oh what has happened so she goes on she
calls in to CNN she calls in to whatever
this radio station and they played all
over cable
I'm sorry I'm sorry da-da-da-da-da and
she said there's a colossal mistake for
which I will and what she doesn't say is
for which I will lose the election Jen's
a for which my current political career
will be over
she's clearly thinking and she's
thinking how can I say that in a way
that gives me an out if by some miracle
I win this election now and so she says
for which I will you know suffer
personal reputational injury and then
she realizes oh my gosh I'm what am i
doing I'm making it about me again I'm
making it all about me the mistake in
the first place is that I made these
women's rapes and sexual assaults all
about me and used it cynically to my own
political advantage and I'm doing it
again and this is what Democrats have
been doing for the entire me to movement
this is what they've been doing for the
entire Cavanagh circus is they've been
pretending to care about sexual assault
and rape and all they're doing is
cynically exploiting it they're actually
injuring the people who have been raped
and sexually assaulted by exploiting
crimes against them for political
benefit to no benefit to the victims or
the accusers or in some cases the
hoaxers to no benefit so she says that
and then and then she has to turn at the
anti she says you know it'll give me
personal reputational injury but I'm not
concerned about that yeah obviously you
are concerned about that that was your
conclusion you said this is so bad I'm
so so sorry and I as a result of this
I'm gonna have my reputation injured
it's not I'm so so sorry these women's
reputations have been injured I'm so so
sorry
these women have been dragged through
the mud or now exposed to the national
news media are now at the height of this
sexual assault national debate
international debate no no you're not
sorry about that you're sorry that it's
gonna hurt your reputation you're sorry
that it's gonna hurt your chances at
reelection and then should all no I
didn't mean that
I mean watches it every which way how on
earth do you mess up this badly I think
it is because Trump is getting in their
heads because everything they expected
everything to fall apart if that guy was
elected president they expected the
economy to collapse us to start a world
war to be in some conflict and when
everything turned out to be exactly the
opposite that it does not compute they
were shocked they didn't consider the
possibility but things will work out if
the Republicans were running the
government and they've just cracked up
they've totally broken down and by the
way that the next line you're gonna hear
out of Heidi Heitkamp yeah and out of
her campaign is that Oh Heidi Heitkamp
didn't know about this ad oh it was just
some low-level staffer oh it was just
some campaign whatever the buck stops
there the buck stops with the candidate
it's true candidates don't run their
campaigns not on the day-to-day that's
why you have a campaign manager the
candidate has to go out and be the
candidate the campaign manager has to be
the manager the actor in the movie has
to perform in the movie and the director
needs to watch everything else but
nevertheless the buck stops with the
candidate if a candidate can't run a
campaign then the candidate cannot be
trusted with the keys to our federal
government period end of story
so a really really brutal it would be a
miracle for her if she if she wins out
there in North Dakota I don't see I
don't see it really happening how about
in Arizona
Kyrsten Sinema Sonoma cinema she has a
lead over the Republican martha mcsalley
still but all of the momentum is in
mcsally's direction so what you know the
Republican candidate was way down here
the Democrat was way up here kind of
floating along now taking a little bit
of a nosedive and mcsalley is shooting
shooting up so the momentum is there it
is a dead heat though it's not as though
mcsalley
is in the lead right now not in a
statistically significant lead so just
at this moment we're already you've got
mcsalley on the upswing
we have released probably is a little
October surprise from the Republicans a
video of sanema saying how much she
hates her own state you couldn't make
this up you couldn't you say okay I I
need some good Oppo to drop in in
October I do you have anything she talks
about taxes or I don't know say well how
about if she says she hates all of the
voters what she says she despises her
constituents and the people voting for
her take a look for if you choose not to
acknowledge the changing nature of your
community and allow instead extremists
to fill the space
created by the natural movement of
change in Arizona could also be your
future Arizona could all heaven forfend
goodness cry hope that Arizona isn't
isn't the future she's saying if you
don't allow change if you don't force me
to go in and change the way of life in
Arizona
and if you don't allow change in other
communities you're gonna end up like
those troglodyte knuckle-draggers in my
home state of Arizona let I mean just a
little bit of political advice to
Kirsten voters really don't like change
when you go in and you say your way of
life is terrible and I want to change it
I want to fundamentally transform it
that creates a resistance against you
and then if you go in and say also I
hate your guts and I hate who you are
and your people are awful not a great
way to win votes it would be it would be
like a presidential candidate having it
uncovered that there was a video of him
saying that he hates Bald Eagles and
apple pie you know like a week before
the election that is the equivalent of
this I mean it's unfathomable that she
would ever make these kind of comments
except that the left has gone insane
it's totally it's lost control of the
narrative so there they used to always
say look the left is just as patriotic
as the right the left we love our
country to dissent as patriotic and we
look but and then you say well but you
burn the American flag you protest the
national anthem you say your
presidential candidate says you want to
fundamentally transform the country
which means you don't like the country
you don't you disliking the country and
you want it to be something different
this is when the truth comes out they've
cracked up they realize they they
actually think that it's in the common
culture that people hate America they
hate the West they hate their community
they hate their countrymen know it son
tumblr it's on blogs it's on Twitter
it's in your own little ideological
bubble where you unfriend anybody who
disagrees with you and anybody that you
disagree with and in that bubble that
makes sense but you've lost an
understanding of everybody else she goes
on it wasn't those weren't even really
her most damn
comments about Arizona here are some
others Arizona is the state of the
crises so cattle copper citrus cotton
climbing we have a sixth seed it's
called crazy in my state Arizona it's
really the meth lab I want to talk to
you about some of the things that might
think that you can do to stop your state
from becoming Arizona Dan must be more
crazy Arizona is the meth lab of
democracy is she like a late-night
comedian is she what is she doing
I obviously this was taken a little
while ago they're not that long ago
cause she looks exactly the same they're
not a good idea if you despise your your
state to try to run for Senate there
you've got you should run somewhere else
you should run where people like you so
I think it's gonna really hurt her the
the momentum was already in the other
direction and this is a pretty good
october surprise for whichever
republican dug this up for it pretty
good stuff and I'm glad they sat on it
we're gonna see a lot more October
surprises and then we have to get to the
best race of all B dough beta male beta
O'Rourke robert francis and texas so
much more as stephen hawking is giving
us a warning from beyond the grave of
the upcoming apocalypse
we've got louis farrakhan we've got
robin williams a lot more to get to
first i've gotta say goodbye to facebook
and youtube
now today at seven o'clock Eastern 4
p.m. Pacific do not miss our next
episode of daily wire backstage with ben
shapiro god-king jeremy boring Andrew
Klavan myself and Alicia Kraus we will
be taking questions but only from daily
wire subscribers so make sure to become
a subscriber today why would you become
a subscriber well you know you get me
you get the end work late and sure you
have the Ben Shapiro show you ask
questions in the mailbag answers
question conversation this this is what
matters this is the straight from the
meth lab of democracy itself the leftist
tears tumblr I don't know where to begin
with this one and also I guess I'm gonna
have to I'm gonna I guess I'm gonna have
to talk a little little trash about our
leftist ears tumblr here now it's
obviously excellent quality
it's an FDA approved vessel it's too
small it's too small we're going to
to get a bigger one hopefully by the
time you subscribe we'll have bigger
we'll have like a Titanic sized vessel
to contain all of them because they're
really really big there's a there's a
way of coming there's a salty leftist
tears way of coming make sure you get
your tumbler
before it drowns you so much more to get
to go to daily where calm we'll be right
back
last but also least beta O'Rourke mr.
bata himself met for the final debate
with Ted Cruz national debating champion
it was bloody it was pretty bad his
campaign not looking great right now I
mean looking great from our perspective
not looking great
for mr. bata so I'll point out beta
O'Rourke raised 40 million dollars in
the third fundraising quarter this is a
40 million dollars this is a huge amount
of money I think it's a it breaks the
record right he took in a huge cash hole
what on earth he needs 40 million
dollars for with three weeks to go of
the campaign not even three weeks left
of the campaign nobody knows we might
have some speculation so he's taking in
all of this money he's not really
spending a lot of it because his numbers
are not great I think right now polls
show Cruz has a seven-point lead so look
it could bethe O'Rourke could win it is
entirely possible if Republicans don't
get out to vote that beta O'Rourke will
win now Greg Abbott has a higher margin
right now the governor of Texas has a
higher margin of victory than Ted Cruz
does according to the pollsters however
nobody is going to go be an avid voter
but not vote for Cruz right nobody's
gonna be an Abbott beta voter so I'm
even a little skeptical of some of those
polls nevertheless beta is raising a ton
of money
it's the largest amount ever raised by a
Senate candidate in a single quarter but
the last record was in the year 2000
when Rick Lazio ran for the Senate
against Hillary Clinton and raised 22
million so let this sink in the last
record that beta worked just beat was
raised by one of the biggest losers to
run the 90th state Senate
he lost to Hillary Clinton carpetbagging
Hillary Clinton moved to New York about
a week before her election campaign and
he lost tremendously and gay and foisted
Hillary on us for another eight or ten
year ever an August 16 years so not
great news if ur work said yeah I've
raised all this look at all this money
that I've raised you think well the guy
you just beat was one of the biggest
losers not a huge victory so that they
met last night crews and O'Rourke for
the final debate
before the election oh where to begin
where to begin take it away mr. bata
first Jason let me thank you and Sarah
from moderating tonight's debate Ken's
five for hosting us the people of San
Antonio for being here and the people of
Texas for watching this and
participating in one of the most
important decisions of our lifetimes
okay
okay starts out basically good I mean
biggest decision of our lifetimes the
Senate race in Texas I don't really buy
that I don't think that the race between
beta or orc and Ted Cruz when the
Republicans control Congress Republicans
control the Senate Republicans control
the house or though the White House is
really one of the biggest decisions in
your lifetime you should rethink your
life if that is the case but okay he's
just speaking typical political
hyperbole go on mr. Beddoe estar aqui
con ustedes otra vez a key in San
Antonio
ooh muy mal muy muy mal Senor beta Senor
robert francis o'rourke robert francis
bate oh oh yes my name's Senor baito yo
hablo espanol don't you know how you
need I need oh okay not helping your
case
Beto O'Rourke is in a fully Irish guy
he's probably a little more Native
American than Elizabeth Warren but he's
still an Irish guy he goes by Beto
because he wants to appeal to Spanish
voters in Texas Hispanic voters but he's
not at all Hispanic and it's absurd and
it's cynical so what look racial
identity politics has become very
important thanks to the left and the
Democratic Party they've made a big deal
about this when you lie about your
ethnicity that doesn't reflect very well
on you Elizabeth Warren has learned this
I think mr. o'roarke has learned this
too what you need to do when you're
called out for this is stop calling
attention to it stop calling attention
to the fact that you're a fraud and a
cynical race hustler what is better work
do he speaks Spanish during a debate in
the state of Texas not not a very smart
move so he he habla espanol with his
Irish brogue then he goes on what's the
biggest hit what's the what
here Eric sock-it-to-me mr. bata what's
gonna be your your clock on Ted Cruz our
junior senator will not stand up to
president Trump someone who apologizes
for Russia defends that country Vladimir
Putin a leader of the country that
sought to undermine our democracy he
won't stand up against him and he won't
stand up for us to make sure that our
elections are free and fair that your
vote goes to the intended candidate this
this is beyond party politics this is
getting this is getting our democracy
back on track and we need a a senator
from Texas who will do that what a
stupid strategy what the Russia thing is
totally empty one
virtually every public opinion poll
shows Americans do not care about
Russian collusion mostly because there's
no such thing as Russian collusion the
FBI hasn't come up with anything
it looks increasingly like a set up by
Democrats we have evidence in part that
it was a set up by Democrats and the
Obama administration in the Clinton
campaign not a great issue why would you
make this your issue by the way there is
talk now that robert muller is wrapping
up his investigation i don't know
they've been saying he's wrapping it up
for months now so i don't know if i
believe it but let me tell you something
if if Muller had something on Trump it
would be leaking right now so give it a
few more days but it would be leaking
right now if they really had something
that was gonna get the president the
United States if it doesn't leak before
these midterms they don't have nothing
they don't have anything so that attack
is a total waste east anne's up to he
doesn't stand up to russia okay and then
he says that Cruz won't stand up to
president Trump this attack also falls
flat there are plenty of good ways to
attack Ted Cruz this isn't one of them
crews fought Trump tooth and nail for
the Republican presidential nomination
he fought him all the way to the
convention and then at the GOP
convention he wouldn't even endorse the
guy he wouldn't even say go out and vote
for Trump he said go vote your
conscience now people might have an
issue with Cruz doing that absolutely
fair enough but that what that certainly
shows is he's willing to stand up to
Donald Trump he's stood up to him for
the entire campaign and he was the last
man standing
in fact that that is probably Cruz's
biggest problem if the biggest problem
facing Cruz right now is he isn't
as being a team player and loyal to the
administration which has been very
successful for conservative policy in
some quarters I think he's been terrific
it actually but in some quarters he's
seem is not not loyal to the
administration okay so by bed overworked
saying that saying that he won't you
know go out and attack Donald Trump
you're actually galvanizing Cruz's base
why does Cruz have a lower have lower
poll numbers than Greg Abbott the
Republican governor of Texas it's
because Cruz has been embroiled in some
of these controversies with the current
president because he's been embroiled in
some controversies his senator bado is
doing bado
Robert Francis is doing Cruz's work for
him here the only thing that makes sense
about this is that he's not running for
Senate right now
O'Rourke O'Rourke is looking at the
numbers he's saying I'm probably not
gonna be able to make up that difference
in the next two and a half weeks so what
I'm going to do is save the 40 million
that I've gotten out of Democrats and
try to run for president in 2020 that's
word on the street from people who are
working on some of these races all I can
say is if you're a Democrat watching
this show thanks hey well that's cool I
didn't know I didn't know you were there
also if you're a Democrat watching this
show give your money donate now to bado
O'Rourke he donate right and give all
the money you possibly can because
O'Rourke is sucking money out of all of
these other swing Senate races and he's
just throwing it in his campaign coffers
to try to run in 2020 so sounds good I'm
sure that Republicans in North Dakota
Indiana Missouri I am sure they Thank
You congressman or work for for taking
money out of races where that it
actually might matter not looking great
not looking great for them not looking
great for him at all we'll see look at
things can change all the time I'm not
predicting anything because they're
always October surprises that come up
even later than this and that might
happen again plus the Federal Reserve
might raise interest rates and put a
damper on the economy I think it's still
a little too late for that to really
matter but President Trump is talking
about this right now so the the big
headline that no one's talking about is
that the US has reclaimed the number one
most compete
country in the world title this is
according to the World Economic Forum
this is the first time since 2008 that
we've had that hmm what happened between
2008 and this administration hmm I've
got a few silver oxide I'm Hussein was a
bit mom no no no a Barack Hussein Obama
that I think I was his name that's what
happened I've almost forgotten about him
because his legacy has been erased
right now we're beating Singapore
beating Germany being Switzerland
beating Japan so great economic news
right now if the Federal Reserve raises
interest rates that could put a damper
on the exploding economy and president
Trump acknowledged this he said the
biggest threat that he faces politically
is the Federal Reserve because the
Federal Reserve is independent monetary
policy unlike fiscal policy is
independent of political machinations
from the elected officials so if they
raise the rates too quickly and they put
a damper on economic growth it could
obviously hit him hopefully that won't
happen but you know this is a big win
for all Republicans this is on top of
the Trump win on the the court ruling
with stormy Daniels and her third-rate
lawyer Michael avenatti this is on top
of getting Cavanaugh confirmed and
Republicans are running hard on the
confirmation of Cavanaugh right now and
all of the other judges this is all
pretty good news so the bad news comes
from Stephen Hawking Steve I know he
died in March how does he have bad news
to give us he has a message from beyond
the grave stephen hawking published a
new book where he explains all of the
awful things that are going to occur to
all of us in near future particularly
around AI artificial intelligence and
gene editing technology so rather than
read the book rather than tell you to
read the book i was a actually able
through the power of voodoo to get
professor Hawking on the phone from
beyond the grave and to get a just a
quick little interview professor what
would you like for us to know was that
are you still there professor did you I
guess he cut out I don't know if that's
talking I know he was a famous atheist
so I don't know if he's talking about
the horror where he is or the horror
where where we're going too bad
who knows you never know where people go
after after this life is over once we've
shuffled off this mortal coil
so he's predicting that things are gonna
look pretty bad for us pretty quickly
he's writing in his new book what while
primitive forms of artificial
intelligence developed so far have
proved very useful I fear the
consequences of creating something that
can match or surpass humans humans who
are limited by slow biological evolution
could not compete and would be
superseded we've heard this before we've
heard these kind of scare stories about
artificial intelligence you know are you
Sarah Connor ah you know Terminator
comes back and they slaughter all of
humanity I'm not that concerned about
that right now mostly because I'm
skeptical of artificial intelligence
ever being creative right now we think
of artificial intelligence as you know
being so advanced it's about to surpass
humans but artificial intelligence
doesn't think the way that humans think
humans are creative I think David
governed her the computer scientist to
Yale made this point decades ago the way
that artificial intelligence works is it
solves problems and certainly the human
brain solves problems but it does a lot
more than just solve problems we think
creatively when I'm you know I'm sitting
there with my khofifah on the table and
I'm you know I don't know Ben and Jeremy
are trying to get me to do work or
something and I'm just kind of looking
at them I'm staring off in the distance
I guys like a you know I'm you would
call that daydreaming I guess is that
think I'm certainly not solving problems
but I am thinking there is some kind of
thinking going on what about when I
sleep when I'm dreaming at night I'm not
solving problems usually in my sleep but
I am thinking there is an intelligence
going on at that at that moment
artificial intelligence doesn't really
capture that and it doesn't capture
inventiveness and creativity I suspect
that it won't be able to do that and I
suspect it will never be conscious
because our consciousness is a
metaphysical question rather than merely
a physical question the relationship of
our mind to our brain and our physical
body and a lot of the people pushing the
AI scariness and spookiness are
materialists who think that there's
nothing in the world other
which is physical and material obviously
we know that that isn't true
because there's love and beauty and
mathematics and transcendence and glory
and virtue and all of those sort of
things okay so I'm not terribly worried
about that aspect of it Stephen Hawking
then goes on he says quote once such
superhumans appear and we're not just
talking about AI anymore he's talking
about superhumans he's talking
specifically about the ability to edit
our genome so right now we have emerging
technology like CRISPR gene editing CRI
SPR to be able to go in to the genetic
you Minh genetic code and delete
malformed pieces of the genetic code
things that cause disease things that
cause deformations in our genes okay
that's good and and that's emerging
technology to be able to try to correct
diseases once we really harness that
technology what would stop human beings
from using that technology to improve
the human genome make us stronger better
faster stronger to quote our future
Republican president Kanye West I can't
imagine what once we have that
technology certainly will do certainly
will do that will create a race of
superhumans here's the fear from Hawking
he says once the superhumans appear
there are going to be significant
political problems with the unimproved
humans who will not be able to compete
presumably they'll die out or become
unimportant instead there will be a race
of self designing beings who are
improving themselves at an
ever-increasing rate and that's
certainly true because once you really
improve yourself you get super smart
super better faster stronger then you're
exponentially going to increase the rate
at which you can improve yourself that
this is a true fear because it raises a
lot of bioethical questions about what
happens when you play God generally
speaking it's a bad idea to play God
doesn't turn out well for people who do
it in the Bible doesn't turn out well
for people to try to do it in history
and it can breed a lot of human misery
that's happened politically with utopian
political movements it's happened with
technological political movements
eugenic political movements like the
Nazis and in the Unites
States for that matter it's not good and
the worst part of it is that our moral
dialogue has been so impoverished that
we don't even have the vocabulary to
talk about these bioethical concerns
during the Bush administration they had
a panel on bioethical inquiry to talk
about abortion cloning in vitro
fertilization that kind of stuff
today it's only 15 years later I don't
know that we even have that ability to
discuss bio ethical questions like that
why even if we can create a race of
superhumans
maybe we shouldn't end it obviously we
shouldn't do that that that's
unfortunate and speaking of our poultry
ethical dialogue Google has gone out and
just basically admitted that they're
going to be evil you know they had that
old quote don't be evil and now the new
motto I think is just be evil I think
they deleted one word it's that's it's
more efficient it's streamlined because
now they're saying
sundar pichai the head of Google is
saying that they're working with the
Chinese government they're exploring
work with them to censor their citizens
to censor political dissidents to work
with one of the most evil regimes on
earth we we know that this is happening
after Google pulls out of a competition
for cloud computing with the Pentagon
with the United States Defense
Department and after they're pulling out
of an AI project with the US Defense
Department because employees at Google
complained that Google was working with
the US military the employees don't want
Google to work with the US military they
do want Google to work with the
sensorial meanest a brutal tyrannical
totalitarian Chinese government that is
a moral idiocy and a moral blindness
that is pretty shocking
it also exposes a point that the Trump
campaign understood in 2015 2016 and
that I think some conservatives are
coming to now which is a questioning of
our idolatry of the free market
obviously we love free market economics
it creates so much prosperity for
ourselves and for the whole world but we
can't make an idol out of it because
there are some questions raised by this
this is what we call neoliberalism
neoliberalism being the advocacy of free
markets free trade free everything
without regard to national boundaries or
national loyalties that this can breed a
lot of good absolutely but if you've got
an American company Google and
essentially American company saying that
they won't work with their own
government to protect their own
government's national interests and they
will work with that governments enemies
with their own nation's enemies to
censor their citizens and maybe give
them technology that could be used to
fight against the United States then you
know that neoliberalism has gone wrong
Irving Kristol who is a neoconservative
that word neoconservative has been
abused to the point of not having any
meaning anymore almost but Irving
Kristol was a left-winger who became a
conservative in the 60s and 70s and
Irving Kristol described a
neoconservative as a liberal who had
been mugged by reality but then he went
on people know that quote he went on to
describe a neoliberal as a liberal who
had been mugged by reality but didn't
press any charges and I think that's
what we're seeing here a real
questioning look I love being able to
get cheap consumer goods I want to be
able to sell cheap consumer goods I want
access to a lot of markets but when you
have one of the biggest countries in the
history of the world and an American
company going in and saying we will not
help out the United States government
and we will help out the government the
United States as enemies and we will
help those enemies censor their own
population and ins helped to enslave
their own population which is what China
has become China's becoming a slave
state with concentration camps cameras
everywhere monitoring citizens facial
recognition I mean a true dystopian hell
then you know that something has gone
terribly wrong in your economic ideology
and maybe it requires changing a lot
more to get to but unfortunately we
don't have time today we're out of time
tune in for backstage maybe we'll talk a
little bit more about those things get
your mailbag questions and that's gonna
be tomorrow and so we'll be we'll be
seeing you then in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael Nolt
show
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018